to really have Fu money in today's world
especially if you live in a large
western coast coastal city you need like
10 million bucks you know for being
honest
there's six sources of income to become
absolutely wealthy today and I've talked
about this many times on my channel
I'm going to expand on it even more in a
book in my follow-up it's and I'm not
going to go into the details but one
it's c-suite jobs CEO CFO CTO that kind
of stuff licensed professionals doctors
lawyers surgeons accountants dentists
whatever
High ticket sales you're selling Yachts
Jets Mansions you're getting a
percentage of that number four is Fame
with an audience it's difficult to
Define but it's essentially actors
musicians influencers people that are
creators you know I would I would
probably distill it down to and they
have people that listen to them or pay
attention what they have to say when Kim
Kardashian says buy my Spanx brand women
in droves click the button and they go
and buy the Spanx brand right
um stem software Engineers tech leads
that kind of stuff I've talked to lots
of guys on consults going through a
divorce grinder that have made seven
eight hundred thousand dollars a year
working for companies like Amazon
Facebook or whatever just doing Cody
stuff like the geeky stuff and number
six is entrepreneurship which is
basically My Chosen path and I'll tell
you more about why you know in this
video and the relevancy between the
plane to win and play not to lose
Concepts
um let's skip over the part about real
estate
tools now now here's something that's
interesting because a lot of people
still get mad at this and I don't know
why because it should be obvious it's
daylight to People by now but the
scandemic was a scam
every so one through five on that list
there where I was talking about CEOs
doctors athletes musicians all this
stuff all of these people
actors doctors athletes lawyers CEOs
they all wore face diapers they all got
jab they all bent the knee they all use
pronouns in their bio when they're asked
to buy corporate they all eat the woke
rainbows and they follow their agenda
because you're still you're still part
of that you still have to conform you
know you still have a governing body in
regards to what it is that keeps your
license on the up and up
um Society doesn't really want freedom
they want free stuff so that's what we
end up voting for generally speaking
okay and it comes to the and it comes at
a price of yielding to their agenda
monkey see monkey do don't ask questions
do as you're told stand on your dots
whatever it happens to be whatever the
next thing whatever the next scam
happens to be whatever that's going to
look like whether it's climate lockdowns
whether it's a new variant of some you
know Airborne virus or whatever it
happens to be
ask yourself how's that working out for
you how did that last one work out for
you you know did you get where you want
you know how many people messaged me
during the last scandemic they are
telling me that if I don't provide uh
proof that I was vaccinated then I'm
going to lose my job what I what do I do
rich I don't want to get this stuff I
haven't seen the tested I don't think I
need it I'm young and I'm healthy but I
have a roof over my family's head and I
have a mortgage to pay and I have
obligations and we're already fighting
so what do I do and it's like what do
you want me to tell you like this this
is what you created for yourself these
are the choices that you make and I'm
going to tell you right now it's not
entirely your fault but it is your fault
if you allow it to happen again you know
the whole Once Bitten Twice Shy sort of
thing right code of The Matrix
anti-fragility
we'll talk about this a little bit more
too
you guys know what anti-fragility is
there's a book called anti-fragile
okay you take
there's three physical States there's
fragile anti-fragile and there's
robustness
fragile you take a glass you drop it
it's going to break it's fragile you
want to ship that to somebody you got to
put loads of popcorn wrapping and bubble
wrapping and put a big fragile sticker
on it when chaos is introduced to that
object It generally fractures breaks and
it doesn't respond well to it you do not
want to be fragile as a human being in
life
robustness is is a better place to be
and that's the equivalent of just taking
a a burlap bag and filling it with sand
I can ship that to somebody and not put
Fragile on the outside of the box
doesn't matter you drop it nothing's
really going to happen right so that's
something that would be considered
robust the concept of anti-fragility is
something that improves with chaos
I said this you know the other day
most businesses most storefronts most
restaurants
um a buddy a good buddy of mine owns a
gym he almost got cleaned out in the
scandemic because he couldn't open up to
the public
um the margins in that suck before that
to begin with but a lot of these
businesses almost got cleaned out some
of them did guys like Jeff Bezos or
Walmart online shopping or Amazon or
Ebay for example did very very well
that's that's that's a concept of
anti-fragility when chaos was introduced
to the equation they improved
I want you to think about that
where in your life where chaos has been
added to your life
has been has been included into the
blender of that you blend up
every day in your life because there's
all kinds of inputs that you put in this
thing right have you have you found an
opportunity to become stronger to
improve when chaos is introduced most
don't
right
you know like at the end of the day
the government doesn't care about you
big Pharma doesn't care about you
employers generally don't care about you
large corporations certainly don't give
a about you Hollywood doesn't care
about you but we and when I say we
we all you know as a culture in society
defer to that as the authority and Trust
you know you'd love to have sovereignty
as a guy but you really don't
they want you on their plan plugged into
lives playing paying taxes in debt
following the rules bending the knee to
the trending thing that controls the
masses right one week it's masculinity
is toxic
Gillette razors right the next week it's
some guy named Dylan that thinks he's a
girl puts on a dress and does
commercials for women's makeup lines or
light beer
now my take on all of this
is the absolute best way to escape it
all is to become an entrepreneur and
build a business that you can run from
anywhere in the world I'm gonna sorry
I'm gonna put the ticker up on the
bottom I should have done this at the
beginning because I've mentioned the
school of entrepreneurship's open there
is a link in the description you can
click that and start there it's it's
only open until the end of the week
the problem though is that
this playing not to lose mentality this
this mindset is infused in every faction
of life including entrepreneurship most
people that start a business within
three years nine out of ten of them fail
so you've got it basically a 10 success
rate if you're lucky and that out of the
ten percent that succeed after three
years of those businesses very few of
them never crack a million dollars in
annual sales they're the mom and pop
shops that are you know opening up a
storefront doing alterations might have
a small hardware shop a landscaping
business a whatever a daycare doggy
walking service
any one of these things right they never
usually crack a million dollars in sales
and what you end up doing is you've
ended up because you've because you've
played not to lose because you've done
the conventional thing that you've
always been told to do you end up in a
scenario where now you're an employee of
a company that you founded maybe with
one or two other people working there
making about the same money as you would
have if you're just an employee at Bob's
company
the biggest difference though is you
don't have
sorry you have more headaches than you
would have if you worked at Bob's
company because Bob deals with all the
Bob deals with any lawsuits
that come in any labor board you know
issues any complaints from HR Bob deals
with all that because he's the founder
he's the owner you just punch a clock
and go home so if you're making the same
amount amount of money as what you would
be if you're working for somebody else
that's actually a better position to be
and sure you get a little bit in the way
of write-offs but you're still paying
the same tax levels because you're still
on payroll the same way that you would
if you would be working for Bob sort of
thing right so this is a very common
mistake that a lot of entrepreneurs make
in life when it comes to making choices
the kind of businesses that they run
I've said this before it's a noble
effort but they've often created a
company that employs them and they and
they pay themselves the same exposed to
greater risk that they have to deal with
right and if the state says oh lock
everything down for the next scandemic
you got to comply and guess what you're
now the owner of the business at that
time right employees were able to go
home collect uh government handout check
you know most of them made out A-Okay
but when they were called back to work
they were called back and they said okay
well now you got to take these uh
experimental jobs
some people will go to college they'll
go and get their degrees their
educations whatever
and um you know those things can cost
tens of thousands of dollars a year and
books tuition you know if you're staying
on on campus and that sort of stuff and
you're basically taught Again by tools
of the Matrix right like I've often said
I'm not a big fan of post-secondary
Education when you get into colleges and
universities and stuff like that because
most most of them today anyway have a
lot of wokeness infused in the in the
culture there's far more women in
universities and colleges today than
there are men
um there would have been a time where
that would have been like a good thing
but now with me too's and false
accusations and like the woke narrative
and the rainbows I want to cram down
your throat
um unless you're in a field in an area
like stem for example or a degree that's
going to give you the right to practice
law or become a surgeon for example they
really don't add up they don't make a
lot of sense right that's the whole
point on why I created the School of
Entrepreneurship okay it is it is it is
a distilled version of everything that
I've learned over the last 26 odd years
when it comes to anything to do with
running a profitable business that you
can run from anywhere in the world and
it's easy and fun right
um there's three circles let me see here
it is
come on
I usually pull these up and put them
back on there's three interlacing
circles a lot of people have asked me
about this and I need to keep this handy
for you
see if the camera will focus see that
when those three things overlap in
business you love doing it you're good
at it and it makes money that
centerpiece that gold part
is where the magic happens I really hope
you guys enjoyed that clip if you want
to watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that eclipse from if
you're newer to the channel make sure
you hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out